There isn't a single male CEO in America
who is not benefited from family planning
and from abortion rights.
Right. Either personally,
because he's able to control how many kids he's going to have
and when he has them with his partner.
But also collectively.
Gender violence,
which is force birth and no reproductive freedom,
is a direct, um,
predictor of an unstable society and a society that is not peaceful,
that. That has high levels of conflict.
And so where we're heading right now is.
Is very dangerous,
not just for individual people,
but for ourselves as a society.
And so I implore every man,
whether he is the CEO of a company
or a member of Congress or a member of our government,
tell us your abortion story,
because we know you have them.